hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast of the topic optimizing the
content and implementation of animal
studies today's presentation is titled
the future of preclinical animal models
in pharmaceutical discovery and
development the science XD ours are
relevant for buses and reproducibility
are critical my name is Julian Chaya and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
lovers for more information please visit
lab reach com if it's your important
announcements to make before we begin
this web test is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them into the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the side window by
clicking on the screen icon in the
roller right side of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the cream Q&A
button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Jeff Everett Jeff ever currently serves
as the director of comparative biology
and medicine at glaxosmithkline rd in
Research Triangle Park north carolina
and also serves as the elgin professor
in the department of pathology at duke
university school of medicine he
received his doctorate in veterinary
medicine [ __ ] canal university and
then conductive residency and
postdoctoral training at the University
of Pennsylvania and the University of
Illinois gives a member of the American
College of laboratory animal medicine
and the american college of veterinary
pathologist and has served in leadership
positions in both organizations he has
led Animal Care and Use programs and has
an active advocate for increasing the
quality of Animal Care and Use and the
translation irrelevance of animal models
he is a former council member of the
Institute for laboratory animal research
of the US National Academies LML turn is
over to dr. Eric for presentation
you Julian welcome to everybody and what
I'm going to talk about today is
something I want to introduce which is
really the topic of this whole virtual
conference which has to do with what i'm
calling the scientific three r's of
relevance robustness and reproducibility
and the objectives of my talk today are
to review some of the present challenges
that are being posed to the use of
animal models in drug discovery and to
discuss the framework of how animal
model research can be improved and the
potential value of laboratory animal
scientists to this process I want to
introduce the scientific three RS which
has really already been introduced in
this conference for the few that have
attended other talks and review some of
the trends in the external research
community that I think are going to
significantly impact animal work in the
future and really this talk in this
whole conference is to provide a call to
arms for laboratory animal scientists to
rally around and to improve the conduct
of in vivo studies now why why is this
necessary and one of the things that
struck me was a recent editorial in the
British Medical Journal which brought up
the question of how predictive in
productive is animal research and it's
one to hear this from the animal welfare
community but it's another thing to see
this in a major medical journal and then
there have been a number of prominent
publications this this is one from
nature which calls into question the
quality of animal experimentation and
here you can see just in the title quite
provocative animal experiments under
fire for poor design and there's been an
awful lot of criticism that's been on
for us tap on the animal using community
of late that really doesn't have to do
with animal welfare but has to do more
with what i would call experiment
welfare and there's a number of common
reds in in this critique one is lack of
experimental rigor failure to remove
bias failure to report properly this in
sufficient detail study design errors
and questioning the biological relevance
of for the questions at hand and I think
that these questions should be extremely
important to us not just for those of us
that work in the pharmaceutical industry
trying to come up with disease relevant
interventions but really for the entire
animal using community and one of the
things that I've been very interested in
as a animal model support scientist in
the pharmaceutical industry is the
translational value of models and here
you can see that over the past two years
there have been a number of prominent
publications that really called into
question on the translational value of
some of the animal studies and these
were picked up in the popular press and
certainly the title on the top got
picked up by the New York Times and its
really created quite a stir and I think
that increasingly in the future attacks
on the use of animals and research is
going to be based upon the science
rather than some of the criteria have
been used in the past which have been
primarily welfare centric in addition to
the questions about translational value
there's been a very serious questioning
of the quality of the research and there
have been there are quite a number of
talks in this conference that I would
refer you to having to do with reporting
of studies and designing of studies and
the entire animal using research process
has been suffering at various minutes
creep reducibility for issues of what I
call quality and we're all all of us
that our laboratory animal sciences are
very interested in the quality of animal
studies and it's going to be important
to really get this in hand and take a
look at this and why both in the popular
press
and in the scientific press now there
has been a serious questioning of the
quality of some animal studies including
very prominent studies now the way I
like to look at Animal Care and Use
almond and this transcends the issue in
the pharmaceutical industry but it's
really the use of animal models in
general is that there has to be balanced
between welfare for the animal and
welfare for the science of the
experiment a question at hand and if you
see on the right there you can see the
NIH poster that's been around for years
it says good animal care and good
science go hand in hand and of course we
all know that to be true but animal
welfare and experiment welfare are not
one in the same and at times I
personally feel that laboratory animal
science has been driven by the animal
welfare agenda a little bit out of
balance and at the cost of the
scientific agenda and I think it's
important that we bring this back into
balance and I think that addressing
these scientific three RS and putting
them at the same prominence that we've
had in the Russell and birch three hours
of reduction refinement replacement I
think would go a long way to address
that balance so what's the crux of the
issue the crux of the issue is that we
need to better plan our animal use
relative to very focused questions that
we're trying to address with animal
studies we need to apply better
experimental design too many of our in
vivo studies there's the need to conduct
studies in a manner that minimizes bias
and some of the earlier talks today on
those of Malcolm McCloud for instance I
would definitely recommend the audience
I listened to if you haven't already
heard them and there's really some
excellent work that's been put forth in
this particular conference describing
why we need to minimize bias and various
ways in which it's best to do that and
the reporting of research needs no rigor
and transparency in or also talks are
going to be more talks on guidance for
location and there were talks this
afternoon about from the standpoint of
journal editors of what is important in
the reporting of research but I think
most importantly it's important for all
of us to realize that laboratory animal
scientists have a cue role to play in
this enterprise wide shift to increase
the quality of in vivo studies now in
the current approaches to drug
development there has been recently
tremendous shifting of how animals were
used in preclinical drug discovery and
preclinical drug safety so in other
words there's been a huge increase in
the number of non animal platforms and
high throughput approaches and very very
powerful ohmic approaches to really just
sect out pathways and really get a lot
more translational science underpinning
how our pharmaceutical compounds are not
just discovered but also how they work
and despite all that animal studies are
still quite pivotal in decision-making
both in pharmaceutical discovery and in
pharmaceutical development in many
therapeutic areas so it is important to
the pharmaceutical industry as well as
an animal research in general to really
get a handle on increasing and
maximizing and optimizing how we conduct
those animal studies and it goes beyond
just deciding well what's the proper
model it really comes down to really
focusing what's the proper question to
ask and then what is it we're trying to
do to answer that question before we can
even get into the issues of the model
and then when deciding on the model
there are issues of translational value
of the model and there's also quality
issues of how the model is conducted and
so all of those things go into a
holistic assessment of how an in vivo
study is put together
now in the pharmaceutical industry
there's been a tremendous change in the
landscape of animal use there's been a
big impact of non-invasive imaging
technologies there's a lot more
telemetric monitoring going on we're
automating many types of sampling in
general animal use has been going down
but the animal models are getting
complex and there's a lot more
multiplexing of endpoints there's also
going to be I think our Renaissance in
the use of genetically modified animal
models to an even greater extent than
exists now with the advent of new
technologies like crisper and talons so
this makes it in my view even more
important that there be some
concentration now on what I'm calling
the scientific three r's and that's to
make sure that animal studies are
relevant to the question is trying to be
addressed that they're conducted with
robust kinds of assays and that the
studies are reproducible and not just
that they can be reproduced but we
really do need to reproduce them and it
is I think been a little bit of a drain
in some areas that animal research has
become so expensive and the time and
cost constraints are so much in animal
based research that many studies really
are not reproduced because there's a
pressure not to reproduce them to
minimize animal use in some cases and I
think it is important for the question
of how robust an assay is and how
reproducible an assay is for multiple
laboratories and animal models to be
performed more than once with many of
our important studies these scientific
three RS are not intended to replace the
three hours of Russell and birch but
rather to place emphasis on the health
and well-being of the experiment rather
than just the health and well-being of
the animals in the experiment
and in the pharmaceutical industry and I
think this can be generalized in a lot
of mechanistic discovery work in
academic centers as well uh there is a
big push now to really make sure that we
understand the translational quality on
the pharmaceutical industry is trying to
reduce the attrition of compounds
through the pipeline and it's
concentrating on really trying to
increase the quality of targets that are
being selected as well as the quality
and drug ability of the molecules that
are used to impact those targets and all
of that pertains quite extensively with
the translational quality that allows
the preclinical program to to predict
and have relevance for the clinical
program that's selected and this is
something that every company and every
drug discovery team is certainly
enmeshed in right now and one of the
reasons for that is that the
contemporary paradigm of drug
development is really an unsustainable
model the cost is just skyrocketing it
currently costs over a billion dollars
to bring a drug to market and that's an
unsustainable cost and so the industry
as a whole is trying to reduce its
late-stage attrition rates and in order
to reduce those late-stage attrition
rates it's important for the preclinical
program both the non animal and the
animal portion to be predictive of
what's going to happen in the clinic to
the extent that it's possible to make
that prediction and so every company has
strong emphasis on trying to reduce the
attrition of drug development so friends
in the pharmaceutical industry in nvivo
and non clinical efficacy research or
that there's a diminution in the overall
animal usage particularly in Discovery
areas there's a diminution in the use of
non-human primates as well as other non
rodent model
there's been an increased complexity to
models and multiplexing of readouts
there's a very very significant
increased emphasis on the use of human
disease relevant phenotypic screens and
increased externalization of discovery
activities to partner in groups either
contract research organizations academic
centers or public private partnerships
and there's also a lot of increased
pre-competitive and collaborative
activities across the pharmaceutical and
biotechnological industry one of the
challenges that we have and um several
of the earlier talks alluded to it is
that it's very very difficult to depend
on the published literature for validity
of research arm many of the targets that
are selected for drug development come
from the literature and many of the
animal models that are chosen for trying
to discern different molecules in lead
optimization programs are based upon
animal models that are published in the
literature and there's a many many
biases that lead the literature cannot
be something that can be easily trusted
and much of this work now has to be
reproduced internally within the
laboratories of companies and
preclinical irreducibility across the
board is a systemic problem that's
driven the current research incentives
that are out there in the publisher
parish academic environment careers are
built on publications in top-tier
journals top journals want simple
compelling stories it's easier to
publish positive studies and negative
studies there's little recognition when
studies can't be reproduced and there's
little encouragement for publication of
confirmatory data so the literature is
not safe for the pharmaceutical industry
to just delve into and take on for next
steps and much work has to be reproduced
and many people are probably familiar
with publications that
have come out of arm engine that were
published by Glenn Begley and uh he was
in a hematology oncology group at amgen
and they took it they looked at 53
targets that were published in top-tier
journals and tried to reproduce the work
in the laboratories and Amgen and found
that a very high percentage of the
published work could not be reproduced
they then went back to the original
laboratories that produced this work and
tried to work with those laboratories to
get them to reproduce their own work and
there was difficulty in getting the work
to be reproduced and this really called
into question the quality of published
targets out there in the literature in
the oncology area and there were a
number of common faults in the reporting
of much of those experiments including
whether the studies were blinded whether
all the results were shown whether there
was replication to the experiments were
the controls proper did they show
positive and negative controls were
appropriate validation of reagents were
often a problem and often the
statistical methods were inappropriate
so there are a lot of common problems
that arose when the when the literature
was reviewed which really brought up the
issue of do we optimally plan and
execute animal studies now arm there
were there are some papers that have
recently come out of the National Center
for the 3 R's in the UK arm that
underpinned the arrive guidelines which
are going to be discussed in detail at
this particular conference but it was
really a survey of a variety of review
publications across biomedical research
and um what Carol kilkenny and
colleagues found that there were
numerous common deficiencies across 271
publications that were reviewed across a
whole variety of journals and they found
that only fifty-nine percent of the
papers that they reviewed even described
objectives and hypothesis adequately
only seventy percent of those papers
describe statistics the vast majority of
the papers didn't discuss issues
relevant to preventing bias such as
blinding and randomization and features
that we know are extremely important in
the output of in vivo studies and so
that led to the development of the
so-called arrive guidelines for
reporting animal-based research and
really these guidelines are a checklist
of 20 different features that are
believed important in the description of
studies and what I would say is that
many institutions are adopting if not
the arrive guidelines themselves then at
least the spirit of the arrive
guidelines by arm looking at developing
criteria for the description of in vivo
studies um Malcolm a cloud you spoke
earlier in this conference has been a
pioneer in sort of pushing for having
good in vivo laboratory practices this
is from one of those older papers but
talking about the importance of sample
size calculations inclusion and
exclusion criteria randomization
allocation group concealment and how
animals are to be excluded from analysis
and how they're to be reported and these
all are important things for in vivo
scientists to consider when not just
designing but also conducting in vivo
studies and I would say that the Devils
in the details and
it's very very important to consider the
type of study and what the potential
readouts from the study are it's hard to
just come up with a single checklist
that takes care of everything in all
studies but it is important for every
individual that's conducting in vivo
research to in the design of their
studies to consider the arrive
guidelines to consider these various
checklists that have been formulated by
different journals that they publish in
and to design their studies with the end
in sight and so that's something I think
is very very important for all
laboratory animal scientists to consider
it's also important to consider that
experimental problems come at all stages
of the life cycle of an in vivo
experiment so while much has been said
at this conference about deficiencies in
the design of studies there are also a
lot of issues that laboratory animal
scientists are most frequently based
within the execution of studies and then
obviously in the analysis of studies and
in the interpretation and reporting of
studies on there are important things to
consider I think that for laboratory
animal scientists though it's very very
important to consider the details of the
execution of the study and it's very
very hard to publish all of the details
of the environment of an in vivo study
everybody's aware that you can't put
your entire a lack site visit document
in the materials and methods of a paper
but there are many many things in that
programmatic description that could
impact an animal study but it is
important for every investigator to
consider what are those things that are
most impactful to creating by us into
creating variation and possible
implications to the replication of their
studies and to make sure that they
address it in all the stages from design
and conduct right through analysis and
interpretation
now much has been said today about arm
two of those practices that are used for
arm increasing the quality of preventing
bias and those are randomization and
blinding but I would say it's not a
simple arm one should randomized and one
should blind I think that the fallback
position should be randomization and
blinding but it's certainly not
necessarily appropriate in all
experiments and also it's important to
describe very carefully how
randomization is done and randomization
can be done in a variety of different
ways and randomized according to a
variety of different criteria depending
on what the nature of the experiment is
it's also important to consider the
readouts of an experiment and where
problems occur in in vivo experiments
because not all the problems of an in
vivo study fall into inadequate
description of the animal you can fall
into an atom inadequate validation and
description of the assay that the
animals being used in in that in vivo
experiment and so how in vivo assays are
developed and how the replication
strategies are designed are extremely
important to consider and that
documentation of the development process
is absolutely critical and the
replication strategy now this is not a
new issue so disick you didn't start
with the arrived guidelines and in fact
there's been advocacy of checklist since
1985 and so it's been well over 25 years
and I think that we really need to start
asking a question of well why haven't
these things been adopted and there's a
variety of reasons that the checklist
haven't been adopted and I'm a little
bit skeptical about all the chick
checklist that are out there checklists
are very important checklists are very
useful tools but we have descriptions of
gold standard checklist and the next one
will be the platinum Stan
we'll have titanium standards and every
time somebody comes up with another
unknown variable on an experiment and
tries to control for it will have
another checklist checklists are just a
tool what's really important is to go
through an experiment with the thought
process of what do we know and that's
where earlier talks on systematic review
and how to properly review what's
already been done is important for
discerning where things can go wrong and
it's also important to consider to
connect principal investigators and
experimental design with those
individuals that actually conduct
experiments because they generally know
where the critical phases are and where
studies can go wrong and where bias is
likely to be generated in an experiment
so it's very very important to consider
the lifecycle from design right through
analysis of results of where bias is
going to come in or a bias may have
crept in so that it can be addressed and
properly reported with transparency and
as an example for the customization of
checklist um many of us are now using
pretty sophisticated non-invasive
imaging modalities and in imaging papers
there are many animal related issues
that need to be very carefully described
and those same issues don't necessarily
need to be described in for instance of
surgery paper that doesn't use imaging
so there are things that need to be
described in every paper and then there
are very important details that you need
to be described in certain kinds of
papers in certain kinds of studies and I
think that it's extremely important for
journal editors to look at the arrive
guidelines look at existing guidance
that's out there and then for their
journals customize those things that
they think are most important to
properly describe in detail because it
is the devil is in the detail when it
comes to describing in vivo studies and
in conducting in vivo studies this is
from a recent paper that I was involved
with which is looking at what's the
minimum information to describe on the
pathology endpoints on an animal study
so the endpoints can affect a study many
times animals are only used to generate
diseased tissues that are going to be
studied and often the lack of
reproducibility or the variation in
studies are due to issues in tissue
handling rather than animal handling so
it's necessary to tie together the
readouts on studies with the actual
conduct of the animal study itself and
it has to be looked at in a holistic
framework so in the review of animal
studies I think it is important to look
at the review process really in two
different ways one is in the ethical
review process and in the United States
really what that constitutes is the
institutional Animal Care and Use
Committee process and that really to me
deals with the traditional three RS see
can you replace your proposed method
with a non animal method can you reduce
the numbers of animals you use or i
would rather rather than say reduce the
animal numbers i would say can you
optimize the animal numbers through
optimal design on in some cases that use
more animals but use optimal design in
other cases I think refining animal
methods and certainly I cook steel with
refinement by assuring the minimization
of pain and distress on experiments
optimizing animal welfare during the
course of that experiment and doing a
variety of animal related refinements
that to me is one type of review it's
critically important it's necessary it's
arm codified in many kinds of animal
using regulations all around the world
in various forms in the US it's in a
form of an ayah cook in Europe and may
be in the form of ethical review
committees but I think it's important
now to go beyond I cook reviews with
really peer interactions in
views on the science of in vivo
experiments and that goes beyond the
things that most aya cooks generally
consider and that really looks at what
I'm calling the 33 scientific ours those
of the relevance of the model the
translational relevance the questioning
of design with respect to biological
plausibility for the questions being
asked the robustness is the in vivo
assays and what's likely to impact them
and the reproducibility and replication
ability of those assays and then i think
is takes a different kind of expertise
it takes different kind of peer
interactions and different type of
review then the ethical review process
and i think to optimize the use of
preclinical models not just in the
pharmaceutical industry but really
throughout in vivo studies i think it's
important to have both of these kinds of
committee and peer related interactions
and we all know slab ritory animal
scientists that there's whole there are
many different things that influence
data hi everybody's heard about all the
changes now that are coming to light
with studies of the microbiome microbial
status is important as far as pathogens
diseases and background lesions of
animals the genetics of models the
environment that these animals live in
is critically important study methods
themselves influence data to tremendous
degree as does the Animal Care news
program and there are a number of tracks
that at this conference to deal with the
training of people and what in the
program influences data but there are
many many things in that program that
influence in vivo experiments and there
are many sources of generic variability
and studies in the pharmaceutical
industry we have a lot of questions
around compound and formulations let
alone dosage and doses dosage
administration animal issues environment
issues as they types and equipment
there's a lot of operator issues
replication and robustness may depend on
how many individuals are involved in the
assay and then there are many many
issues of that affect variability when
it comes to the analysis and reporting
of results now with that all said arm
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
arm in in my work at GSK how we look a
little bit at some of the issues of
translational science with preclinical
models and I want to credit a number of
my colleagues at GSK primarily Brian
barrage and and others in discovery
pathology with coming up with an animal
model selection assessment framework
that we use for translational relevance
um one of the first things we do is we
ask what the human condition is that
we're trying to develop interventional
therapies for and what what is the
disease and disease entity that we're
trying to develop that there before and
how well do we understand it okay so in
order to model something you have to
understand what you're trying to model
and you have to understand how the model
that you're choosing to use is going to
model the process and so we ask how well
characterized etiology and pathogenesis
of our patient disease population is how
well characterizes the role of our
putative molecular target the intended
pharmacology um how discreet is the line
of sight from our intended pharmacology
to the clinical outcome of interest and
how well is our intended patient
population characterized with respect to
demographics genetic heterogeneity
comorbidities than other issues that
affect the disease process and also
what's critically important is
understanding if there's a characterized
and translatable biomarker that would be
available to help bridge between the
preclinical program and the clinical
program
we also are interested in aspects of
preclinical model physiology how well is
the systemic and molecular physiology of
our intended patient replicated in the
in the model that were intending to use
does that model replicate the relevant
systemic anatomy and physiology does it
replicate the relevant molecular
physiology this is critically important
particularly as our therapies get more
and more specific around very specific
intended targets on and often we're
trying to modulate very very exquisitely
sensitive and specific pathways we want
to know about the how the model
pharmacology stacks up does the model
replicate the expected pharmacology and
patients is the molecular target
conserved in the species that were we're
trying to model in is there evidence
that modulation of the target net
species produces a relevant biological
effect is there evidence that the
modulation of the target is going to
have a similar effective in patients so
it's also that's just the primary
pharmacology it's also important to know
about possible secondary pharmacology
that are affected when you hit the
target and we want to know whether the
models position to characterize that
secondary pharmacology because that can
have very very important unintended
consequences and we want to know whether
that translatable biomarker a
pharmacology exists so that we can go
between our preclinical model with
clinical patients we also want to look
at how well our model may model disease
how we're often as veterinarians most
familiar with disease models but really
disease models are only a one subset of
the total preclinical modeling picture
we're using and in many cases we're not
trying to model a disease in an animal
that's present in a patient population
we all know that there are
on differences between animal diseases
and human diseases but in the case of
disease models we want to know if the
ideology is the same is the pathogenetic
time course similar how well does the
model replicate the clinical outcome
does the model replicate the clinical
phenotype or is the phenotype different
what about the pathophysiologic pathways
that lead to the phenotype are they
similar and does our intended study
design replicate our intended clinical
trial on with the dosing regimen that's
going to be used to affect the patient
population it's also important to know
whether there are disease comorbidities
and are we replicating those
comorbidities in a relevant way in our
animal model and also here in disease
models it's important to have
translatable biomarkers went in if
possible so using those four categories
of looking at our animal model relevant
to disease patient populations that
makes up what we call our translational
matrix and those go to the one are of
relevance and that's how we look at is
the model we're choosing relevant to
some of the patient questions that we
intend to address and it's very much
that framework that helps us bridge the
preclinical program in the Discovery
areas to ultimately the intended
clinical outcome because one of the
things that we we really are trying to
do in trying to reduce attrition in the
pharmaceutical industry is make sure
that the thing that's paramount
obviously is patient safety but we also
do not want compounds to fail late stage
for lack of efficacy and really to show
that something is that the cases you
really have to consider all of these
questions in that translational matrix
so arm really in starting to summarize
this I would say there are a variety of
opportunities for improvement of how we
conduct animal models I think that we
have to deal with both the translational
relevance of our models but also there
are tremendous opportunities to improve
the experimental design the experimental
conduct as well as the experimental
reporting analysis and reporting of in
vivo studies and so I think there are
profound quality issues that we as a lab
animal community are going to have to
address and there's also armed animal
modeling issues that I think we as an in
vivo scientific community are going to
have to really get our hands around in a
much stronger way in the future um I
think there's improvement in equality of
many of the things we do with our
animals not just I think over the last
several decades we've certainly
increased the quality of our animals but
the use of our animals um as reagents
still can be improved we're learning
more all the time I think the microbiome
emphasis of the last two years is really
going to translate into us looking much
closer at our animal models with even
more rigor I think in general that in
vivo studies um really have to
concentrate on the reagents that are
used in the pharmaceutical industry
there are issues of formulation that are
absolutely critical it's one thing to
properly dose an animal it's another
thing to properly the compound in the
excipient in in the proper way and
blinded fashions with root concealment
not know what your dosing it's very few
animal studies are actually double
blinded and many of us at times feel
that if we conducted clinical trials in
the manner that we conduct our
preclinical animal study
with very small groups of you know six
to ten people and we did it in a
non-randomized non blinded fashion we
would be quick to say that people don't
translate to other people and certainly
there have been many late stage problems
in clinical of experiments where the
early stages of putting formulations
into people didn't seem to predict so
it's critically important to make sure
that there's rigor at all steps of this
process and I think there's a lot of
room in the reporting of studies for
journals review bodies granting bodies
and scientific oversight bodies to make
sure that there's less bias in the
system in selecting positive rather than
all studies that have been conducted and
we all have to to make sure that we
don't demonstrate behaviors of failure
to reject our favorite hypothesis and I
would say that this whole area is been
very important and that's why the
committee at this conference chose this
particular scientific topic as lab
animal science topic this year but it
also was the topic of an aisle our
roundtable at the National Academies
where reproducibility of animal based
research was was the focus of a workshop
that brought together many different
stakeholders and it was very clear at
this workshop that arm this quality
issue in the conduct of in vivo studies
really has to be looked at with more
rigor and the reporting of studies has
to be revolutionized really and how
journal editors deal with these things
and there have been a number of
important topics raised at this
conference that I think will be the
subject of the laboratory animal science
over the next
okay to be honest and one of the things
that I think is important from the
standpoint of those views that are in
preclinical work in the pharmaceutical
industry is the need to really
distinguish between exploratory and
confirmatory preclinical studies so I
think many academic and many mechanistic
studies are what i would call
exploratory studies as well as many many
industry studies but there are times
where and I think exploratory studies
while they require the same design
conduct analysis and reporting rigor as
do confirmatory studies I think they're
of a different nature than confirmatory
studies and I think that you can get
away with a lot a lot more on in
confirmatory studies that are really
mini-challenge studies or many efficacy
studies looking at will a preclinical
model serve to demonstrate efficacy of a
therapeutic intervention these have to
be conducted in a much more rigorous
fashion and I think in a much more
analogous fashion to what we've learned
in the clinic with the conduct of
clinical trials and um there was a nice
earlier discussion today by armed the
group in the Netherlands arm looking at
the the use of systematic review as an
aid in designing studies and also
mentioning the Cochrane Collaboration
which has really been at the foundation
of increasing rigor and quality in
clinical trials and for the first time
now they're taking up the issue of how
preclinical animal studies are conducted
and I do think that there are very
strong linkages to make in how we do our
pre clinical efficacy work and then
bringing all the results of that work
into the drug development paradigm for
taking into the clinic and recently
there's
been armed uh some discussion of
multicenter arm preclinical randomized
control trials of looking in preclinical
models at therapeutic interventions
putting the data together with um well
construed meta-analysis and really
conducting those preclinical studies
across academic centers in a way that's
very analogous to how works conducted in
the clinic and I think that we're going
to see more and more of this in the
future so with that arm I'm going to
conclude by saying that I really think
that this conference ought to serve as a
call to arms that steps need to be taken
to improve the planning the conduct the
reporting and analysis of animal studies
I think the laboratory animal scientists
who work in the discovery support space
have a very significant role play for
implementing what I would call the
scientific three hours of relevance
robustness and reproducibility and I'd
like to leave everybody with the thought
that the health and welfare of the
experiment is just as important and
perhaps more important in many respects
that is just looking at the health and
welfare of individual animals on those
experiments and with that I'm going to
stop and um we can take any questions
Julian are you there yes hi Anne Preece
oh thank you for that informative
reputation before we get started on the
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you to submit questions by
typing them into the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window you will try to
answer as many questions as we can I'm
not just waiting for some questions
thank you
you
greatly okay um so uh there's there's a
question on arm how diseases and
laboratory animals are modeled on for
ethnic variability and diseases and
that's an extremely good question arm
their arm there's a big effort in the
pharmaceutical industry to really under
to try to understand in patient
populations of these genetic
underpinnings of disease and certainly
the polymorphisms are present in the
patient population are studied by
genetics groups within the
pharmaceutical industry and where
appropriate obviously a species strain
and stock differences are taken into
account for trying to understand how
those polymorphisms may translate into
research animal populations and there
are also many new technologies that are
coming out in genetic animal models on
many of you are probably aware of things
like the collaborative cross in the
mouth biology arena and there are a lot
of new and potentially important ways in
which genetic modification of animals
are going to be used in the future for
trying to model those differences in the
human population into trying to aid us
in the development of personalized
medicine okay if there are no more
questions I would like to once again
thank dr. Jeff Everett for his
presentation do you have any final
comments uh no other than to encourage
of the audience to attend many of the
other talks in this conference I think
that the subject matter of this
conference was summarized a bit in my
talk but each of those various areas of
the
scientific three ours is I think
critically important for us to continue
to work on and is a subject of more
detailed discussion in some of the other
presentations so thank you to everybody
who attended great today's webcast will
be available for argument viewing
through six months from the writing
you're receiving email from Roberts
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for retype invite you to
follow that in absolute dear colleagues
you may have missed today's live events
see you next time and goodbye